بنام في ممرات في البرد
وفيج ساعتين بناهم مع بعض تقريبا الي 65
يوم بالمستشفى الاوروبي قصف البيت علينا
طبعا وبنتي راحت رجلها وزوجتي تقريبا عطل
90% في رجلها والحمد لله والبيت
والسياره
معف بنات ثلاثه وزوز اناس عننا خبط مش
طبيعي طول خبط رجع قول خبط عنا وص طبيعيه
وبنام في الورب والله يمكن 80 يوم او 90
وزي ما انت شايفه يعني الامور صعبه ما
بعرفش ننام الوحش في الليل ساعه حده ننا
بنام في ممر عمليات زي ما انت شايف انامله
ساعتين ثلاثه من دوشه الناس وم دوشه
البنادمين والدنيا طول نامه في الليل وفي
الليل وفي النهار واحنا قاعدين
بدوش لا بح ولا بنا لبين الدنيا بنامش ولا
بنرتاح
خبر
حتى طول مش عفيفي يما كثير كثير نازحين
بشكل مش طبيعي والناس تعبان الكل انت قاعد
جنب الكل بعل الكل بقح كمان الكل مريض
الكل تعبان وفيش احج امور مش نلاقيه مكان
النام في المدرسه المدرسه ناموا فيها هي
اولاد نصهم بيناموا في المدرسه ونص البنات
الصبايا ناموا في المدرسه وانا بنام في
الاورب لا نوم ولا صحه ولا عافيه وبفكر في
اودي وبفكر في حياتنا في الباساء اللي
احنا عايشينها ابعاد عن اولادنا وعن
بناتنا وعن قرايبنا وعن كل اللي
بيقراه